hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast fighting against air
physiologic oxygen and reproducibility
presented by dr. Alicia hen chief
scientific officer biosphere ik's
I mix a briga tiers of libraries and I
will be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars and before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and those offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits app located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Hen I will now
turn the presentation over to her all
right well thank you Xavier and thank
you to lab reeds for giving me this
opportunity to speak with you all today
I'm going to get right into my
presentation here and then and please
invite you again please send me
questions I always love to talk about my
favorite topic here and let's get
started so I may be the only presenter
today that's going to ask you to close
your eyes start off our talk I want you
to close your eyes and imagine your own
cell biology lab stand in the doorway
and think about what you see what you'd
normally see there
you see chairs you see tables you see
benches you see equipment and I'm gonna
ask you what of all that do your cells
actually need because I'm gonna make the
case and here you can open up your eyes
but I'm gonna make the case here that
your cells don't need any of that they
don't need any part of your traditional
cell culture lab we're going to talk
about today what cells actually do need
what do they need cells don't need the
chairs and tables and equipment they
need unbroken physiologic conditions
that's really what cells need and part
of what we do biospheric
is trying to prevent to present that
environment for cells wherever you need
the cells to be we present a psycho
centric environment for them so this is
what cells usually see in a traditional
cell culture lab they see an incubator
that's easy for people to use it's easy
to get your hands in there it's easy to
get your face in there but we all know
it's not actually the optimal
environment for cells it's easy for
cells to get contaminated in there and
conditions are highly variable they're
not physiologic every time the door
opens and shuts room air mixes with
incubator environment which which is is
causes variations in the environment and
that door doesn't open and shut the same
number of times on a Sunday as it does
on on Monday we all know that so how can
we make an environment that's better for
cells
well biosphere X we make equipment that
provides site eccentric incubation in
that the doors on the incubators open
only to controlled cell handling space
so that the cells are kept in optimal
conditions wherever you need them to be
it's like being able to put your hands
right in the incubator and manipulate
your cells without the cells ever having
to come out into room air likewise
people-centric cell handling is open to
the room
this is biological safety cabinet where
the cell
are at suboptimal conditions they're at
room air temperatures which is
hypothermic for the cells they're at
room air carbon dioxide levels which is
hypocapnia for the cells and their room
air oxygen levels I'm going to spend
most of the rest of this talk talking
about oxygen levels but this is hyper
oxic for the cells and i've got a
reference there to a paper there if you
want to look more into more detail about
how this cell environment and the room
air environment is interrupted by people
actually just working in that space if
you want to see more information about
that a site eccentric cell handling is
closed meaning that we take any
equipment that the cells need and we put
it into that optimized cell space so
microscopes centrifuges cell sorters
whatever equipment you need for cell
care or cell analysis we can put into
this enclosed and optimized environment
for the cells whether it's huge
pipetting robots like this large
automated Tekin robot we enclosed
whether it's for bio printing bio
reactors you name it we can enclose it
into a space that's optimized for the
cells and in that's that cell space
there's no room air it is just filtered
tank medical grade gases that are used
to provide that atmosphere so we can
dial in the co2 the o2 whatever
conditions we want for those cells you
can also control particles we can
control of a volatile organic compound
fumes we can control all these critical
cell parameters to make sure that the
environment is optimized for those
particular cells more broadly the ex
vivo system that we build for our
customers is an entire site eccentric
facility that can protect an entire
process from start to finish
so that once your cells go in
they can stay in staying controlled
optimized conditions out of highly
variable room air for whatever you need
to do for those cells the entire time
you've got them whether they need to
grow and differentiate whether you need
to get data out of them or whether you
need to get a sell product out of them
we can control the environment for all
of that now it doesn't have to be a huge
ex vivo system like this either to
provide better conditions for your cells
we also make smaller chambers that you
can put into an existing incubator to
optimize conditions for cells in an
existing incubator as well I'm going to
talk a little bit more about these and
show you some data that some of our
custom ater customers have generated
with this little later so the sine of
centric approach what that really means
is really taking the cells point of view
and in this case I'm going to talk about
how important oxygen is from the cells
point of view it seems like a very
fundamental thing but it's not something
that we talked about enough we're gonna
talk about the best oxygen levels for
cells both in vitro and in vivo now
oxygen and vivo can really be broken
down into two large categories of
factors those are factors that are so
relevant as such as the cell type that
you're studying what those cell cells
are doing whether they're what kind of
state they're in
and there's also site relevant factors
I'm gonna start with these site relevant
factors to talk first about oxygen and
in vivo so I shouldn't vivo is really
all about the same three L's that you
see in real estate location location
location it's all physiology driven as
soon as you breathe air in from room air
room air oxygen is about 21% oxygen the
minute that enters your upper Airways
it's already mixing with air that you're
exhaling so the oxygen level immediately
drops so even in your lungs oxygens down
to about ten thirteen percent oxygen not
anywhere near what room air air is
and oxygen levels go down from there and
each organ type can have very different
oxygen ranges depending upon the
physiology of that particular
environment for the cells excuse me but
you notice that all of these oxygen
levels are far lower than the room air
that we that we where we work with cells
in traditional cell culture an oxygen
and rebo is never any one value because
oxygen isn't present in just one one
level it's always in present ingredients
and it's always in flux because oxygen
is always being delivered and being
consumed to different tissues at
different rates so you get these very
tissue specific oxygen ranges and those
oxygen levels will fluctuate there's
even one paper that claimed that they
they were measuring oxygen levels very
close to the Perry capillary wall
outside the circulation and they are
able to see what they saw as oxygen
fluxes as single red blood cells passed
by that one spot so oxygen is very
difficult to sort of pin down to one
specific number it's always in ranges
and it's always changing
also as you move away from for blood
circulation oxygen levels drop quickly
in normal healthy tissues so you can
have very low oxygen levels in normal
healthy tissues and then there are
special areas that are particular
interest right now are the research and
clinical areas such as the bone marrow
niche for stem cells and these this area
is kind of interesting because it has a
different physiology in this area you
have sort of this River Delta of the
sinusoidal blood flow where blood
vessels interconnect and the blood
vessel wall fins out and these the web
vests will spread out so that what
actual flow rate slows down there which
means that more oxygen can get pulled
from the blood supply in the area as its
passing through these areas and the
slower flow rate leads to lower oxygen
levels in those areas so it's very much
physiology driven and this balanced
oxygen being delivered oxygen being
consumed of course is disrupted in
pathologies where you might have issues
with the vasculature and one very
well-known pathology of courses and
tumors where you don't have good blood
vessel development for that tissue and
you can get hypoxic areas at the center
of these tumors that can be extremely
low in oxygen there's also very high
competition rate for oxygen at those
sites so you get naturally very low
oxygen levels and then there's areas
even vary across small areas such as in
the the b-cell germinal Center in the
tissue you can get different oxygen
levels in different areas aware is like
in the the the light zone you can have
low oxygen levels in the dark zone you
can have high oxygen levels and as the
cells circulate between these different
levels between these different areas
they're subjected there's a different
oxygen levels and they have also very
different functions in these different
zones which really leads to a lot of
very interesting questions that people
are exploring now about the connections
between different oxygen levels across
very small scales in vivo and what that
means for self function in the
intestines and normal intestines of
course the high competition rate from
the microbes in the in tension in the
intestines will cause a very low oxygen
level on the luminal side of the
intestines whereas on the other side you
can have very high oxygen levels because
you got good blood flow so you can get a
high oxygen gradient across those
tissues in normal healthy tissues in a
disrupted pathologic state such as
inflammatory bowel syndrome however they
think that
signals that some of these cells might
be experiencing some hypoxic stress some
as if they're not getting enough oxygen
so there's some very interesting
pathology related oxygen effects going
on there as well
wounds of course are also an area
because you've got bad delivery of
oxygen and high competition from perhaps
microbes at that where oxygen plays a
critical role in being able to heal
those wounds there's a recent paper on
by Evan board called the importance of
controlling in vitro oxygen tense
attention to accurately model in vivo
neurophysiology which was published
quite recently in neuro toxicology in
which he really lays out the case that
if we're not using oxygen levels that
are more reflective of the in vivo
situation that we're not looking in the
right place for answers to our most
pressing questions about neurophysiology
and here he shows on a scale the in
vitro oxygen levels that these cells are
being exposed to and how far away they
are from normal physiologic levels in
the brain and pathophysiologic oxygen
levels in the brain so you can see
there's very much a compelling case to
using a proper oxygen levels for cells
and trying to mirror what's going on in
vitro other pathological high states may
include ischemia reperfusion are high
altitude sickness or motor schema
conditioning all of these are cases of
course in which oxygen is absolutely
critical parameter that must be
regulated in vitro so I'm going to stop
here for a minute and change gears and
talk a little about words talk about
terminology and talking about using
relative oxygen reference frames when
we're talking about oxygen as a state
the old terminology traditional
terminology has been really formulated
on using room air as the reference frame
so room air is called more maxia and
anything lower than new than room air
would be called hypoxia which would
include all the physiologic ranges of
oxygen whether they're actually
pathologic or whether they're
physiologic and that doesn't really give
you much room for going hyper oxic in
any sort of in vivo relevant frame so
when we start talking about physiologic
oxygen it leads to a lot of confusion
because now you're norm Axia physiologic
norm axia actually isn't that room air
it's actually much lower oxygen level
and anything that's hypoxic you want to
be pathologic but it can't be and you
want to be able to talk about hyperoxia
because too much oxygen is also
stressful and damaging for cells too so
but being able to use these we're trying
to reuse these norm at sia hypoxia terms
in a physiologic frame as opposed to the
room air frame makes it quite confusing
and we've seen actual cases where you
know trying to use the same term hypoxia
whether it's physiologic or pathologic
has led to actually erroneous
conclusions for instance you can take
the same oxygen percentage-wise say 5%
oxygen and we try to apply that across
different states physiologically and you
can get either a pathologic hypoxia
situations such as 5% oxygen will be too
too low for perhaps a upper airway cell
it might be just right for a cell
capillary endothelium it might be far
too high for something like a bone cell
or a contra site that would normally be
exposed to very low oxygen levels
so because different oxygen states
really depend entirely upon the
physiology we encourage people to sort
of switch reference frames when it comes
to terminology move away from this
people centric room err term nor maxia
because there's nothing normal about
room AR for cells and tissues and start
using the term fizzy axia which is more
Saito centric because it really shifts
the frame of reference to the
physiologic state well coming back to
our oxygen relevant facts factors let's
talk about the soul relevant factors now
talk about cell type differentiation
state activation state one of those
cells are functioning to proliferate to
migrate and and how important it is to
regulate oxygen for for those and here
I'm going to talk a little about amino
metabolism because this is a new
exciting vibrant field that's really
sprung up quite recently just in the
last few years
fine what we were all taught in our
basic biochemistry classes about
metabolism and tying it in new ways to
solve function in in such a way that we
can we're seeing that basic metabolic
machinery does more than just support
cell function it really controls it so
what we are all taught was that cells
when they have plenty abundant oxygen
tend to use oxidative phosphorylation
using oxygen as the final electron
acceptor in metabolism and when cells
are deprived of oxygen they'll switch to
glycolysis excuse me well we're finding
is that there are conditions where cells
will use glycolysis even when oxygen
levels are high even when they're given
more oxygen they don't seem to be using
it to switch and switching to oxidative
phosphorylation
but using glycolysis machinery
which is really interesting because in
the past we really thought about
metabolism functioning mainly for energy
production but we know that for immunity
you need also affect our reactive oxygen
species production and you need biomass
production and this biomass production
made me why cells are choosing
particularly T cells and T lymphocytes
are using glycolysis rather than
oxidative phosphorylation so cells use
they seem to be using different
metabolic pathways when they're in
different states so naive lymphocyte may
be have his needs are a relatively low
energy low biosynthetic rate they tend
to use things more of pyruvate and more
fatty acid oxidation and more oxidative
phosphorylation
okay so cells at different states are
using these different metabolic pathways
once you're resting lymphocytes starts
dividing rapidly then it seems to switch
to glycolysis in order to support
biomass production that needs for the
daughter cells
likewise hematopoietic stem cells which
we find in that niche site in bone
marrow also tend to use aerobic
glycolysis there is a seminal paper
published in 2016 something out of the
Carl Jun lab about car t-cells and how
important metabolism is for the car
t-cells and they found some very
interesting things looking at cells that
were using different different car key
molecules that had different co
stimulatory modules in them finding that
those that were that had 4:1 BB
co-stimulation had increased fatty acid
oxidation increased oxygen increased
proliferation
increase survival in vitro and a
different t-cell phenotype and that they
had more central memory than the ones
that we're using the cd28 car in these
cells tended to be more glycolytic and
have more effector memory phenotype also
there's evidence out there that CTLs and
culture regular CTL solidity cells in
higher oxygen culture tend to use more
fatty acid oxidation and have more
proliferation going on
wherein lower oxygen they tend to have
more lytic activity and less
proliferation going on and also their
cytokine profiles are different as well
so oxygen for sporty cell culture can be
absolutely critical we also have a
recent collaboration with pro map and
Asya that resulted in a wonderful poster
being presented at the Carty summit just
a week or two ago and I'd be happy to
share a link to that if you're
interested please let me know and they
presented the latest data on on using
controlled oxygen environments for karti
environmental optimization so what do my
cells need let's come back to this
question again I I don't know what cell
type each of you is working but I can
tell you without a doubt that room air
oxygen is irrelevant for your cell type
at best but we all have to work with the
cells in vitro so let's talk about
oxygen in vitro so in vitro oxygen comes
from the incubator and your room air
incubator is not at 21% oxygen which is
a fact that doesn't get a lot of airplay
as well as something you might not be
aware of because of the increased co2 of
course of our pumping into the room our
incubator and because of the increased
humidity in a room air incubator you
cannot have 21%
oxygen in there because 21% is what room
air oxygen is and the completely dry
outdoor sea level environment so if you
calculate it out the the most oxygen you
can have in there is about eighteen
point six percent when we actually went
around in measured room air incubator
oxygen in several different institutes
across upstate New York
we found that averaged about 17.2% when
you first closed the door over first
couple hours now if you open and close
the door on your ink you Bator that
tends to perturb the oxygen level quite
a bit because when you open the door
the co2 all rushes out of your incubator
and oxygen from the room rushes in and
then when you close the door again and
we've all seen this you close the door
in your ink you Bator and a little light
comes on says that co2 is charging up
and we we watch the co2 go back up to
five percent but we don't think about is
what's happening to the oxygen level
while that's happening the oxygen is
going out that little sponge in the side
of the incubator in the back because the
airs got to go somewhere if the co2 is
charging up right so you can actually
drive the oxygen level all over the
place in your room air incubator just by
opening and closing the door so just
putting one of these chambers inside of
your incubator one of our C chambers in
there will help control this variability
that you see from the incubator door
being open and shut and then if you put
multiple chambers in there you can even
have multiple environments in there for
your cells that you know are well
controlled so oxygen in vitro comes from
the incubator it has to pass through
several phases before it actually gets
to your cells there's the gas phase
outside your cell culture vessel there's
your gas phase inside the headspace of
your cell culture vessel and then
there's the liquid phase of your cell
culture vessel that also has to go
through and oxygen is very
corely soluble in aqueous medium so this
isn't a trivial thing the depth of the
medium has a big effect on how long it
takes that oxygen to get to your cells
if they're laying on the bottom of the
subculture vessel and how dense those
cells are or how fast your oxygen
consumption rate is also will vary as
your cells expand so we say that Perry
cellular oxygen is completely protocol
dependent and that all of these factors
go into what the actual oxygen level it
is that your cells see and incubator
oxygen in vitro also comes from the
refrigerator and what I mean by that is
that it because oxygen is so poorly
soluble in aqueous medium it takes hours
for it to equilibrate with the gas
levels in the incubator and so it is
really essential that if you're trying
to control oxygen levels that your cells
see that you precondition medium or
other liquids that your cells are going
to be exposed to to the proper oxygen
level to reduce the time that they're
out of optimum you need to work fast and
you need to work smoothly with them in
the BSC to minimize mixing with room air
while you're working with them and doing
that you can be very successful in
controlling an oxygen level that your
cell see but you have to you have to
know how to minimize the time that
they're out of optimum but they're only
out of the incubator for a few minutes I
hear this all the time because oxygen in
vitro comes from the room as well when
you handle yourselves so why do we need
full-time physiologic simulation for
these even for self handling well
there's a paper published in 2015 by the
Brock's Meyer group which showed this
very very clearly they defined a term
called extra physiologic oxygen shock
where they showed that cells during
isolation when they're first taken out
of the body if they're exposed to room a
our first little is 15
they could have a rapid deleterious
effect on those cells and on their
function they're working with metabiotic
stem cells in that case and it's because
of this this protein we know a lot more
about this than we used to
if one alpha in at room air and cells
are being exposed to room air oxygen to
play displays one of the shortest
half-lives amongst cellular proteins
it's controlled entirely at the protein
level not the RNA level not the DNA
level is controlled at the protein level
which means that even short periods of
time out of optimum can actually affect
cells I'm showing you this from one of
the early papers on hip 1-alpha and I
just wanted to show you the timescale on
these figures it just takes we're
talking single minutes of here out of
optimum for those cells to be affected
and downstream of hip one are absolutely
critical cellular functions we're
talking about functions that affect
metabolism cell death cell cycle
differentiation and all of these cell
signaling intermediates and growth
factors are affected by different oxygen
levels through the action of hippo and
alpha so oxygen is fundamental but it's
complex when oxygen levels fall for
cells that can increase if ones stiff
ones stabilization which can increase
your glycolytic enzymes increase your
glucose transporters and in lymphocytes
as I mentioned before that that affects
their phenotype affects their function
it's also affects the functioning of
natural killer cells R and K which are
becoming more and more important
clinically it also affects myeloid cell
function macrophage there's also one
phase of the cell cycle it's not
regulated by a cyclin CDK x' rather
is regulated by the redox state of the
cell which means that if you have a lot
of reactive oxygen species present there
because cells are trying to deal with
oxygen levels that are too high that can
fundamentally affect cell cycle no
matter what the cell type we have a
collaborator University of Rochester
that has been doing some work with B
cells and they've been able to show that
different oxygen levels using this
chamber gives some very different B cell
functions in culture so it looks like so
culture oxygen is critical for B cell
function as well and also for core blood
HSC and if oxygen levels are too high it
can very much be impaired the function
of home at a paper done under cells as
shown by this paper by Roger Ron
recently so I'm going to shift gears
again here and talk because I've talked
about oxygen and vitro we've talked
about oxygen vivo as one of these
critical cell parameters that are so
important for getting the best data out
of ourselves and getting some data
that's relevant out of ourselves
relevant for the in vivo situation and
we'll talk a little bit about how
controlling these conditions is critical
for better reproducibility because once
we can control the environment wherever
the cells need to be in the lab then we
can really set about improving sulfate
so in our conventional cell conditions
every time you bring those cells out of
the incubator your oxygen is going off
you co2 is going off the temperature is
going off the pH is going off and then
you put them back in the incubator and
those cells have to recover after the
medium is finally recovered two
incubators state in site eccentric full
time optimal conditions you don't have
these cells being thrown off constantly
and
optimal conditions they have full-time
optimal conditions we can take these
different modules from our XP web
systems and combine them in different
ways to put them around any type of
process that you need to do with your
cells so whether you need some
instrument chamber to control oxygen
there are incubators with a processing
chamber we buffer chambers and laminar
flow all of these work together to
create this constant optimal Saito
centric cell conditions and once you've
set up those modules in the way that you
need them for your process you can you
can do this early in the research stage
and then reuse those same modules over
and over as you build your cells build
your product toward clinical preclinical
and clinical studies and in the end you
end up with a completely GMP compliant
cell production system risk contracts
with the best traditional clean rooms
that we've got even in the highest tech
most advanced clean rooms that we have
people are still using incubators in BSC
so you still have this same variability
for cells because it is primarily a
people centric environment not a Saito
centric environment for those cells with
a Saito centric environment for
yourselves you can control not all not
only all the cell parameters and you can
lock down the best optimal conditions
for yourselves but then you can take
those conditions and you can put them
anywhere in the world and clone them you
can have verifiably the same conditions
for those cells whether you're in San
Diego whether you're in Saudi Arabia or
whether you're on a ship at sea you can
have verifiably the same conditions for
the cells so while when we talk about
the reproducibility crisis for cells and
we've talked a lot about factors like
differences in reagents we talked about
factors like reporting problems we
talked about
style identity problems and bad uses
statistics there's one factor that goes
into every single cell based assay
performed on the planet and that is cell
conditions and that is something we need
to get into the larger discussion on
reproducibility so taking the capability
for full time optimization and full time
monitoring we can reduce the variability
that you see from experiment to
experiment from day to day from year to
year from user user we can take the
ability of full-time physiologic
simulation and use that to reduce the
variability see went from translating
from in vitro to animal from a new vitro
to human when we can take that cloneable
environment that modular expandable
environment and use it to reduce the
variability we see from lab to lab from
location to location and in transferring
our results from research to preclinical
to clinical GMP so production so I'd
like to stop there and leave some time
for questions and please feel free to
reach out to me at with my email I also
come find me on LinkedIn I run the in
vitro reproducibility group there I'd
love for you to join the discussion come
join us there see what we're talking
about and check out our blog wwf/e XCOM
floor slash site eccentric thank you
very much thank you dr. Han for that
informative presentation we will now
start the la the Q&A portion of the
webinar and we'll address some of the
most commonly asked questions by our
viewers if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button our speaker
will follow up or three questions via
email let's get started
our first question is cells have grown
fine in room air incubators for decades
why change now well that's a really
interesting question
there have been some publications
recently that have shown that cells that
are grown in room air oxygen even for
decades are still being affected by the
higher oxygen levels their their TSH
levels of glutathione levels are off the
redox status is off and they may give
erroneous results because of this oxygen
artifact that is imposed on them by
being grown in room air oxygen so even
for cells that have been in culture for
decades it's still very important to use
physiologic oxygen levels and if hif
levels change that fast in room air
oxygen how can I ever get good data if I
work in a room air East yes II yeah III
get this question a lot because we know
that oxygen levels can effective levels
very quickly but because your oxygen is
poorly soluble in cell culture medium
that gives you a little bit of leeway to
be able to change that medium as long as
you using pre equilibrated oxygen levels
for in your media it gives you a better
chance of not disrupting the the hip
status of those cells if you work
smoothly work quickly in a BSc and i
know our customers have been able to do
it with our chambers so i know that you
can do it of course working in a
completely enclosed and controlled cell
handling space like in our ex vivo is
gonna give you absolute control and you
don't have to worry about those factors
and I've seen papers that said that
hypoxic culture didn't make a difference
why should I go through the trouble to
work in low oxygen
yeah well we didn't understand if and we
didn't understand how quickly cells were
regulated by oxygen changes before we
really knew about if one alpha so there
have been a lot of studies out there
done with out the proper conditions for
controlling oxygen well for cells that I
think have given very confusing results
and misleading results and we're seeing
more and more papers now that people
have better equipment they have better
options detection ability and they have
better processes for controlling oxygen
for cells we're getting better data the
oxygen actually is absolutely critical
for most cell types all right and our
last question I don't have space for a
big system like that in my lab do you
have anything smaller that can allow me
to control oxygen during cell handling
yes we do we have a full range of
products that can control oxygen for you
for both incubation and for cell
handling for all different sized spaces
and all different budgets so and all
different needs so please contact us and
we can guide you to the best technology
that would fit your space in your budget
all right well I would like to once
again thank dr. Han for her presentation
I would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through December of 2018 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye